-♪♪ Hashtags ♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪ Hashtags ♪♪
-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
UnhappyCamper tweets
from you guys.
Here we go.
This first tweet is from
@BatesEricka.
She says, "My family was singing
'Kumbaya' together
when the park ranger came
and asked
if we could keep it down
or pick a new song."
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's what you do
when you're camping.
-Come on!
-Come on, dude.
-"Sorry, everybody,
but do you know 'Fancy'?"
All I got.
[ Laughter ]
This one is from @brockstar35.
-Yeah.
He says, "My friend though
it'd be funny to wake us u
by shooting a shotgun
right by our tent
and yelling
like someone shot him."
[ Laughter ]
-That's not funny.
-It is funny a little bit,
but --
-No!
[ Laughter ]
-What's wrong with people?
That's insane.
This one's from @KaraMarie6791
She says, "I thought
I packed a tent,
but instead I accidentally
packed a pop-up soccer goal.
[ Laughter ]
Aw, no. Useless.
Useless on a camping trip.
-No, not good. Not good at all
-It might even trap animals.
I don't know what it would do.
This one's from @MarcMacWebb
He says,
"Pulled off the road
late one night
to set up camp.
Thought we found
a really nice spot
but woke up on a golf course."
[ Laughter ]
"This is perfect, man!
Let's just unpack right here!"
"Fore!"
-[ Imitates golf ball flying ]
-This one's from @Juliaaa888
She says, "At the sleepawa
camp I went to,
we weren't allowed to say
the word 'hate.'
Instead we had to say
'un-camperific.'"
[ Laughter ]
-Ew.
-Much harder to say.
-I'd un-camperific that.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @dannyp58.
He says, "Every night we threw
dead fish in the girls' cabin.
They thought the fish
were jumping in the cabin
out of the lake."
[ Laughter ]
-Wait.
-I don't think so.
I think you thought
they thought that.
-Yeah, you thought
I don't think
they ever thought that.
-"These fish are jumping
out of the lake
and opening the window
and jumping in."
-Oh, my God! How far away?
The lake's 2 miles away!
-"Every night, it's happening.
I can't believe it!"
[ Laughter ]
"I'm gonna buy more gems."
-♪♪ Boop boop boop boop
doo-doo boop ♪♪
-Last one here is from
@preschlteacher.
She says, "I took
an air mattress
on a camping trip
but forgot the pump,
so I slept on the ground
all weekend.
Got home to realize the pump
was built into the mattress.
[ Laughter ]
There you go. There you have it.
Those are our
"Tonight Show" hashtags.
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags
-♪♪ Hashtags ♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
OneTimeInClass tweets
from you guys.
Here we go.
This first one is from
@ianwilkie.
He says, "I grew a rat-tai
over the summer.
In school, the girl
sitting behind me
cut it off on the first da
and said, "I'm not staring
at that all year."
-Justice never sleeps.
[ Laughter and applause ]
This one's from @Tweets4J.
She says, "A student
fell asleep in class,
so the teacher changed the clock
to 3:00 p.m.,
shut the lights off, and
had the class wait outside."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's a cool teacher.
I like that.
-Come on, that's a cool teacher.
Tweet!
-This one's from @dorseyreinke
She says, "I was turned around
talking to the guy behind me
when the rubber band
on my braces snapped
and landed in his mouth."
[ Audience groans ]
"Ew!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Uh..."
-Boing!
Bing!
[ Laughter ]
-Doy! Toots!
This one's from @RachelAlbert.
She says,
"I grabbed a sweatshirt
from the dryer and put it on
When I got to school,
I pulled out a pair
of my dad's underwear
from the pocket."
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Chuckles ]
-Oh, my God!
♪♪ Yadda-dadda yadda-dadda
♪♪ Dadda-da tweep ♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Last one's from @IAmAlexGallo.
I wonder who tweeted that.
-Who was it? Who tweeted it?
-I -- I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @IAmAlexGallo.
She says, "A girl was supposed
to introduce me to the class
She said, 'This is Alex,
and she's a virgin.'
I was a vegan."
-Whoa!
-A vegan!
[ Laughter and applause ]
There you have
the "Tonight Show" hashtags.
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags
We'll be right back
with Kaley Cuoco!
Tweeting, everybody!
♪♪♪♪
-♪♪ Hashtags ♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Tonight I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
MyKidIsWeird tweets
from you guys.
Here we go.
This first tweet is from
@JarenMcCormick.
She says, "My kid told me
that my butt
looked like a bag full
of chicken nuggets."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Is that weird?
-Yeah, it's weird.
-It was more of a truth-teller
-No, it's weird.
This one is from @mollyligonn.
She says, "My nephew once
sneezed out a Sour Patch Kid
I still have no idea
where it came from."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"We didn't have Sour --
Where'd you..."
-"He hasn't eaten one of those
in 10 years."
-"I found it on the sidewalk."
[ Laughter ]
This one's from
@facelessukulele.
-Oh, wow.
[ Laughter ]
Love face.
-That name is taken on Twitter
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
She says, "One of
the kids in my class
came out of the bathroom
and quietly said to himself,
'Well, that hurt.'"
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Huh?"
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @timdrake.
He says, "My friend's kid
will just stare at him
and meow when he's hungry,
since that's what the cat does
to get food."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Meow!
This one's from @jodyandmatt
She says, "My son told his class
that my job is
that I 'stand at a hotel
and guys come to see me.'
I work at the front desk."
[ Laughter and applause ]
What?
"Guys come to..."
[ Laughing ]
"I stand at a hotel,
and guys come to see me."
-Never stays the night.
He's only there
for a few hours a day.
And then she gets paid.
-Uh...
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @BaristaSimmer
She says, "When I caught
my daughter picking her nose
she said,
'I'm putting it back in.'"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-It's a Sour Patch Kid.
This one's from @jehedgesphoto
She says, "My 9-year-old
daughter asked,
'Mommy, when I grow up,
will my boobs be
as long as yours?'"
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Go to bed."
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @TMCully.
She says, "Found this --"
this is a picture --
"Found this
on the dining room wall.
Asked our 4-year-old son
what it meant.
He said, 'You can't know.'
It says "horse hair."
[ Laughter ]
That's weird.
"What does that mean?"
"You can't know."
[ Laughter ]
-"You must never find out.
-"Horse hair."
Last one's from @Jenboston
This is a photo.
She says, "My 3-year-old asked
to have her picture taken
with store mannequins."
Here's the photo.
[ Laughter ]
That's cute, that's cute!
There we go.
Those are "Tonight Show's"
hashtags.
To check out more
of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags